good morning john now i would not
normally release a video on christmas
eve but a bunch of people who have been
working for decades one of the most
exciting scientific instruments ever
built are going to be releasing that
into space on christmas day so i could
not help myself i made a video about the
james webb space telescope and how
amazing it is going to be on this
channel 10 years ago and now it is
headed to space this is an endeavor to
help answer real deep human questions
some of the biggest ones like how do
planets form is there life elsewhere in
the universe and how does the universe
work you can't do what the jwst wants to
do from the ground and to understand why
you have to remember that light is made
up of lots of different frequencies we
can only see with our eyes a really
narrow band of those frequencies but the
web wants to see specifically in
infrared for several different reasons
the big one being that the universe is
expanding and so things that happened a
long time ago and are very far away
their light has actually been stretched
by the expansion of the universe and
it's been stretched into the infrared
but there's a problem with this which is
that infrared radiation comes off of
anything that has heat and basically
everything has heat but the exceptional
reality of the web is that at the tiny
dim levels of light they want to measure
from exoplanets or the beginning of the
universe if the telescope itself is warm
at all the mirrors will radiate infrared
light that would overwhelm the
observations so the telescope has to be
extremely cold so you need to block out
all sources of heat particularly the sun
but also the earth and the moon which
shoot off enough infrared radiation to
heat up the telescope too much so the
telescope has to have a heat shield that
can block off of that heat but it needs
all of those sources of heat to be in
the same direction so the heat shield
can block all of them at the same time
luckily there is a gravitationally
stable point on the opposite side of the
sun earth system and that is where the
web will orbit keeping its solar panels
and sunshield pointed toward the earth
and the sun while on the other side the
telescope thanks to its five giant heat
shields will be cold enough to liquefy
air the launch and deployment of the
jwst is going to be extremely tense it's
scheduled right now for christmas
morning 7 20 eastern time and that
launch is gonna be tense but it will not
be the end of the tension so just so you
know what we're in for in the path to
making these tremendously valuable
observations here are the biggest size
of relief that we are going to
experience over the next month the first
one will come about 33 minutes after
launch when these solar panels will
automatically deploy because that means
we are in space and the craft can power
itself 12 hours after launch we have the
first burn now remember the web cannot
be refueled it has all the propellant it
will ever have so depending on how
accurate the initial launch was this
course correction could use more or less
fuel and using less could potentially
add years to the mission so another big
reason to worry right here three days
after launch you start the five day long
process that is to me the scariest the
deployment of the sun shield each of
these tennis court sized sheets are
thinner than a human hair everything has
to go right it has been tested and it
all should the temperature difference
between one side of these sheets and the
other side is 600 degrees fahrenheit and
finally the biggest weight comes off of
everyone's chest 13 days after launch
when the mirrors and some other
important bits of the telescope have
been fully deployed and it will be ready
to be a telescope and the final sigh of
relief happens 29 days after launch when
the telescope will be at a stable orbit
at l2 at which point the web will have
been successfully deployed and the team
will spend a further four to five months
calibrating and testing the telescope
before five to six months after launch
we received the first ever images from
the james webb space telescope john i
don't know what the point of being a
human is but i know that somewhere close
to the root is curiosity we want to make
the world better for ourselves and for
other people but even without that
concern i think we want to know we want
to learn we want to look really deep
into ourselves into our world and into
our universe and in a very literal way
we are about to see deeper than we ever
have before the jwst launch is scheduled
for christmas morning 7 20 am eastern
time john i'll see you on tuesday